PASSIVE AGGRESSION?
>>> WHO THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD
IDEA TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO USE
DRUGS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE WORST
DRUG EPIDEMIC IN HISTORY AND
FLIPPING OUR SOCIETY UPSIDE
DOWN.
JOE BIDEN'S DOJ MAY LEGALIZED
SUPERIZED DRUG CONSUMPTION SITES
TO USE NARCOTICS AND DIE.
THEY ARE GOING TO DECIDE ON THIS
IN A MATTER OF WEEKS.
MICHAEL SHELLENBURGER ONE OF THE
VERY FEW REPORTERS AUTHOR OF
"SAN FRANSIKO."
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
>> WE ALL SAW BIDEN FAMILY SAW
FIGHTING FOR HUNTER BIDEN FOR
MANY YEARS.
WE WANT TO FIGHT TO RESCUE THEM
SO THEY CAN RECOVER FROM
ADDICTION.
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
CONSIDERING LEGALIZING ADDICTION
MAINTENANCE SITES.
ALL OF OUR MAJOR CITIES.
THEY WANT TO SPREAD THEM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
NATURALLY IN POOR BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS.
FIGHTING FOR OUR LOVED ONES AND
GIVE UP AND GIVE INTO ADDICTION.
TO GIVE INTO THE DISEASE OF
ADDICTION.
EVERY REPUTABLE EXPERT
ABSOLUTELY WRONG APPROACH.
YOU NEED TO MAKE AN
INTERVENTION.
THESE DRUG SITES ATTRACT VIOLENT
DRUG DEALERS WORKING FOR CARTEL
AROUND THE SITES.
SAN FRANCISCO, WE GOT IT SHUT
DOWN AFTER SIX MONTHS SUCH A
DISASTER ON THE STREET.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ACTIVELY
CONSIDERING LEAD LEGALIZING
MODERN DENS AND OPENED UP IN
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT A NEW
IDEA?
NO SOCIAL SCIENCE TO SUGGEST IT
WORKS.
HAPPENED ALL ACROSS EUROPE IT
DESTROYED PEOPLE.
WHAT IS THE MOTIVE?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND?
>> I MEAN IT IS REALLY CRAZY.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER ALSO, VERY
ACTIVE EFFORT IN THE UNITED
STATES TO SHUT DOWN CIGARETTE
SMOKING.
WE GOT RID OF SMOKING AREAS
OPENING UP FENTANYL AREAS.
PEOPLE ADDICTED TO HARD DRUGS
AND SHOULD BE ENABLED IN THEIR
DISEASE TO SELF-MEDICATE.
IT IS PLAYING OUT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
>> AT THE SAME TIME THESE SAME
PEOPLE ARE TELLING US IT IS
DANGEROUS TO USE NATURAL GAS
STOVE BECAUSE OF EMISSIONS.
THEY ARE NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
SMOKING METH?
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO WONDER
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
I DON'T KNOW.
S
>> YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER PART OF
A BROADER MOVEMENT WESTERN
CIVILIZATION IS A TERRIBLE
THING.
FOUNDED ON SLAVERY AND GENOCIDE.
MAYBE WHEN THEY START TO DO
THINGS THAT UNDERMINE
CIVILIZATIO
CIVILIZATION.
>> Tucker: MICHAEL SHELLENBURGER
DONE MORE REPO